et monsieur grains de quoi va-t-on
parler aujourd'hui bien aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler d'un nouveau smartphone
c'est celui là c'est le poke om3 on se
situe dans l'entrée de gamme chez poko
alors je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
yamoo peut-être deux ans et demi je sais
plus exactement vous avez amené avec moi
sur le premier lancement français et
européen même probablement de poko
c'était poko fan f1 aujourd'hui pour qu
est une marque qui veut toujours partie
du groupe shiori et qui se détache avec
son identité propre
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle vous
n'avez plus de logos de chiots minul pas
nulle part vous avez un poco poco m3 et
surtout un smartphone qui se situe dans
l'entrée de gamme on va donc regarder
qu'est ce que peut vous apporter ce
poème 3 est ce qu'il est fait pour vous
est ce qu'il est intéressant quels sont
les points positifs qu'elles sont si les
points négatifs et vous savez que dans
l'entrée de gamme je vous le dis à
chaque fois mais c'est vraiment tout ce
qu'il faut savoir
les bacs viennent vraiment montrer les
muscles par rapport à l'autonomie par
rapport à une très grosse batterie est
ici une fois de plus la plage par
l'ombre et c'est une fois de plus c'est
le carnet une très grosse batterie de
6000 millan paire eur waouh énorme
on va donc se mettre juste au dessus on
va regarder ce poko m3 on va voir s'il
intéressant et surtout s'il est fait
pour vous
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisé en partenariat avec vivid les
services bancaires se révolutionne avec
l'avènement de nouvelles applications
très innovante et aujourd'hui je vous
parle de vivid monnaie c'est une
application bancaire d'un nouveau genre
qui vous permet de gérer plusieurs
pocket pour mieux gérer votre argent
les pocket sont comme différents comptes
qui vous permettent d'attribuer votre
argent comme vous le souhaitez comme par
exemple acheter un nouveau vélo préparer
des courses de noël ou tout simplement
pour mettre son argent de côté on peut
créer gratuitement ces pocket pour mieux
gérer son argent au quotidien et vous
pouvez également profiter de cashback
jusqu'à 10% par achat et jusqu'à 100
euros par mois grâce aux achats que vous
allez faire avec votre carte
une partie du montant dépensé va vous
revenir sous forme de cash back
c'est une façon assez maligne de
dépenser son argent votre argent sera
alors récolté dans votre pocket gains et
actions qui augmentera au fur et à
mesure vos achats vous pouvez commander
dès maintenant votre carte en métal
gratuitement et elle vous permettra de
retirer de l'argent en france ou à
l'étranger jusqu'à 1000 euros par mois
avec un minimum de 50 euros par retrait
et payer vos achats dans 150 devises
sans vous soucier du taux de change et
sans aucun autre frais supplémentaires
vous pouvez contrôler votre argent
facilement grâce au système de
protection basés sur l'intelligence
artificielle de vivid mode et vous
pouvez suivre vos dépenses facilement
grâce à un organiseur intégré vous
pouvez vous fixer une limite pour
certaines catégories
vérifiez vos prévisions dépenses
personnelles et obtenez des analyses et
des informations détaillées sur vos
habitudes d'achat et vous pourrez
également recevoir ou envoyer de
l'argent facilement entre amis
l'application vivid monnaie et ultra
sécurisé vous recevrez des notifications
instantanées sur l'activité de compte et
vous pouvez bloquer ou débloquer votre
carte très facilement depuis votre
application je vous invite à cliquer sur
le lien en bas dans la description pour
découvrir vivid monnaies ouvrir un
compte gratuitement
et recevoir jusqu'à 100 euros de cash
back tous les mois regardez moi comme
c'est mignon cette jolie petite boîte
bon c'est vrai il ya pas beaucoup
d'informations ici est mise à part le
modèle la grosse batterie ils nous
montrent effectivement à toutes les
applications google qu'on peut utiliser
sans leur trouve un petit peu partout
bon quelques infos très simple je vous
passe la boîte parce qu'il a vraiment
pas grand chose à raconter je vous
montrais le smartphone ou leur
smartphone il y coule déjà vous l'avez
vu en un capteur d'empreintes digitales
ici vous posez appelle votre doigt tac
ça déverrouille est d'ailleurs puisque
pourquoi tu marques
chehoumi bien j'ai une bonne nouvelle
pour vous on vous offre un xiaomi 1 me
disent tu es pour participer c'est
facile vous cliquez sur le lien en bas
dans la description vous participez au
concours et vous aurez peut-être la
chance d'être tiré au sort pour repartir
avec votre ministère ça c'est cool
vous allez voir le design il est assez
marrant est assez particulier surtout au
niveau du dos c'est un plastique qui est
imprimé qui vous donne une espèce de
fois et fait cuire
c'est drôle parce que des smartphones
avec des effets cuir comme ça j'en ai
pas connu connu beaucoup il y en a mais
c'est dans le haut de gamme on est
vraiment dans autre chose on est pas du
tout là dessus mais c'est du côté de
chez au pot avec son finepix de pro une
fois de plus pas même revêtement mais
l'idée faux cuir derrière ça me fait
penser un petit peu là vous vous en
douterez au en écosse maarten de poko je
crois que là ils l'assument vraiment
vraiment vraiment vous avez un triple
module photo je vous montre la
configuration dans quelques instants
prise jack sur le dessus ça c'est plutôt
pas mal vous allez avoir de l'infrarouge
également si vous souhaitez utiliser
votre smartphone comme une petite
télécommande des micros pour la
réduction de bruit ici double nano
symplus carte micro sd c'est pas mal
votre micro ici vous le recharger en usb
si vous avez votre haut parleurs et puis
vous avez surtout un écran de 6,53 booth
résolution 2340 par 1080 pixels à 395
pixels par pouce et du full hd + voyez
vous avez une espèce de petite encoche
là qui est planqué ici c'est un
smartphone qui fait 100 98 g vous pouvez
trouver soit en noir comme ça soit en
bleu sois en jaune
moi j'aime bien comme ça je trouve
vraiment très très très neutre mais il
est le comme ça en jaune je sais pas
mais je pense c'est un petit peu plus
criard après si vous aimez le jeune
pourquoi pas mais vous avez surtout un
écran qui est certifié lutter contre la
lumière bleue un ratio de 19 points 5/9
et il occupe 90 5 34% de la face avant
et vous avez un verre corning gorilla
glass 3i sommet la certification white
vine l1 qui vous permettra de regarder
votre contenu sur en est depuis x mick
hannah les compagnies en full hd
bientôt qui est assez marrant et qui a
noté ici c'est que vous avez des hauts
parleurs stéréo votre haut parleurs
principal se situe ici sur le côté comme
on trouvera un petit peu classiquement
niveau de tous les smartphones il va
utiliser également le haut parleur vous
avez pour passer vos appels
téléphoniques en tant que deuxième haut
parleurs stéréo
alors je vous fait écouter c'est très
compliqué se rendre compte comme ça je
sais il faudrait vous puissiez l'avoir
devant vous ce site vous décrire un peu
tout ça
internet ici enfin le tout est vachement
drôle si vous voulez c'est bon il ya
quand même un certain déséquilibre
je vous cache pas que le haut parleur
principal ici en voit un peu plus de son
que l'autre sera un peu plus feutrée
mais il va venir vraiment en renfort en
a vraiment une sensation de renforts qui
vient de la gauche de votre écran
ça apporte à l'image stéréoscopique
c'est pas dingue dingue mais il fait
plus le smartphone n'est pas trop cher
on est dans l'entrée de gamme
je vous donne le prix dans quelques
instants ça vient apporter vraiment à
l'expérience multimédia le son si vous
le poussez trop fort var tendance un
petit peu saturé de une fois de plus
c'est normal vous pouvez utiliser un
casque avec votre prise jack et en plus
vous avez des bluetooth 5.0 pour
brancher un casque que son fils puisse
compter sur un smartphone d'entrée de
gamme on va pas avoir réussi les
meilleures performances
on tourne sur ostende dragonne 662 vous
avez 4 gigas de ram
lp dédièrent 4x et vous avez soit 64
giga de stockage onu et fès 2 points en
soit 128 giga de stockage en ef s 2.2
dans les deux cas extensible jusqu'à 512
il ya de stockage ici pour faire tourner
quelques jeux du plastoc ça ira
vous n'allez pas avoir l'expérience la
plus fluide la plus rapide une fois de
plus on est dans un smartphone d'entrée
de gamme je vous le rappelle mais pour
jouer à quelques jeux
sa frappe et ça c'est un truc que je
vous ai dit plusieurs fois les marques
pour les smartphones d'entrée de gamme
cherche avant tout à mettre en avant de
grosses batteries une très grosse
autonomie
c'est là où ils vont vraiment venir
essayer de vous draguez 5 millions en
paire eur 6 millions par ici 6000 milles
et amp erreurs on se dit que plus
chiffrée gros et mieux ça va être alors
ça va dépendre bien évidemment de
l'intégration ça va dépendre de votre
processeur ça va dépendre de pas mal de
choses
je dois reconnaître ici le smartphone
est assez endurant plus ça dépend de
vous et de vos usages mais vous pouvez
le garder jusqu'à deux jours sans
problème
attention quand même si vous passez des
heures et des heures et des heures à
jouer dessus ou à regarder des films des
séries vous en douterez évidemment on
parle ça va descendre mais sinon sur un
usage un petit peu plus modérée et un
peu plus standard sa smart phones que
vous pouvez garder deux jours sans
problème et en plus ce qui est bien
aussi c'est que vous avez un bloc de
charge 25 watts inclus c'est pas la
recharge la plus rapide il faut vous
armer de patience pour nouvelles
recharges et de 0 à 100% si tentez vous
vouliez leurs charges et de 0 à 100%
donc pensé bien dans le recharger
lorsque vous avez du temps devant vous
pour ne pas être pris de court côté
logiciel on tourne sur amy winehouse
pour poko vous avez votre tiroir
d'applications classés en différentes
catégories
oui bien naviguer dedans très facilement
communication divertissement
photographie outils achats jeu mode de
vie financé à faire connaissance
éducation très simple à utiliser très
efficace d'un point de vue logiciel
aujourd'hui le nombre de capteurs vous
allez voir à l'arrière de votre
smartphone bien c'est un vrai engouement
marketing ici une fois de plus on vous
dit que vous avez 3 capteur à l'arrière
en réalité pour moi vous en avez un les
deux autres c'est vraiment histoire de
se marrer vous avez un capteur principal
ici au centre 148 mégapixels couvre f
1.78 savez que vous allez faire toutes
vos photos à côté vous allez avoir de la
macro 2 mégapixels f 2.4 et un capteur
de profondeur 2 mégapixels f 2.4 autant
dire que ce n'est pas cela que vous
allez venir utiliser le plus tandis qu'à
l'avant plan cas ici vous avez une
caméra de 8 mégapixels qui ouvre à f 2.0
ici c'est vraiment du pur marketing mais
reconnaissez le si vous devez choisir
entre un smartphone qui a un seul
capteur à l'arrière et incarne à 3 vous
allez sur lequel vous allez probablement
aller sur celui canal 3
même si vous allez utiliser qu'un seul
en règle générale on se dit qu un prix
identique on n'en veut plus
mais c'est là où c'est intéressant et
c'est là où le discours marketing est
bien fait et très malin et ici poko
n'est pas le seul à le faire tous les
autres constructeurs le fond vous voulez
en avoir pour votre argent et ça paraît
bien évidemment normal donc on vous en
mai 3,8 ok j'ai acheté un smartphone
avec trois caméras l'arrière mais non
vous avez acheté un smartphone avec une
caméra à l'arrière
vous n'allez rien faire de votre mac row
peut-être histoire vous marrer un peu au
début mais vous allez rien faire je vous
montre le résultat dans quelques
instants
et avec votre capteur de profondeur vous
n'allez pas faire grand chose de plus
ce n'est pas un smartphone qui est fait
pour faire des photos en mode portrait
pour faire de la macro il peut le faire
certes mais ça servira à rien maintenant
par contre vous avez un 14 48 mégapixels
c'est plus intéressant je vous montre le
résultat on va commencer pour une photo
prise avec la caméra de celle filles oh
là là là là ça me lis mais ça ne lis les
regarde et je me suis tendu la barre
bien je me trompe je ne me rase pas
comme ça mais ça vous savez tout sur ma
vie eh bien regardez là j'ai
l'impression d'avoir une peau de banane
visitait de gros du ve et puis là ça
ressort c'est bizarre ça me lis ça me
fait un truc voilà je bon moi je passe
je n'aime pas je passe on arrive sur le
capteur principal sont les 48 mégapixels
bon une fois de plus on est dans
l'entrée de gamme
on voit qu'il a un peu de mal avec le
ciel là qui est quand même relativement
cramé je pense que là dessus vous
sortira de belles photos dès lors vous
avez beaucoup de lumière un grand ciel
bleu pour le reste il fera pas de la
magie non plus j'ai quand même tenté un
zoom numérique fois deux chats kupper du
bruit s'attendent le lycée quand même
déjà que tu as quand même un peu de
bruit je marche au terme de gestion de
lumière il a quand même beaucoup de mal
mais ça c'est normal j'ai tenté jusqu'au
faillite il y va mais bon il souffre un
petit peu caméra principale reprend de
l'autre côté sur mon 48 mégapixels je
vais être plus comme en ciel est bien
cramé j'ai mon vraiment de précision de
tous les côtés s'ébruiter sait pas où et
je continue ici il voyager un peu plus
de lumière de ce côté là c'est un peu
moins difficile c'est vraiment ça qui
permet de vous dire que lorsque vous
allez avoir beaucoup de lumière sur les
beaux jours pour des souvenirs des
photos de vacances
why not mais dès que les conditions
deviennent plus hasardeuses tout de
suite il y aura un peu plus de mal
on va tenter un peu de maquereaux alors
on peut faire des petites choses il faut
savoir qu'ici vous n'avez aucun objectif
de stabiliser il faut trouver votre
bonne distance bon voilà pour moi les
faits voilà il n'ya pas grand chose une
fois de plus je vous dis la macro vous
n'avez pas utilisé ici
quant au mode portrait et bien vous
pouvez si vous voulez il va des tours
est pas trop mal mais je trouve que ça
lisse c'est pas extraordinaire et pour
moi en l'état s'est pas particulièrement
exploitables voilà donc ce qu'il fallait
savoir sont ceux poko l3 est ce que ce
poko m3 est fait pour vous ça c'est la
vraie question ça c'est la bonne
question
eh bien je dirais que si vous avez un
budget compris entre 160 euros à 180
euros
il peut être fait pour vous parce que le
prix très exact ces 159 euros 90 pour la
version 4 gigas de ram 64 giga de
stockage ou 179 euros 90 pour les
versions toujours cadillac drame mais
128 gb de stockage c'est très drôle
parce que chez beaucoup de constructeurs
dès qu'on passe du
64 ou 128 les prix s'envolent là vous
avez 20 euros des cas 20 euros d'écart
autant vous dire que la version 4 + 64
je ne vous la recommande pas 20 euros
effectivement ça reste toujours de
l'argent mais ça vaut le coup de les
mettre pour venir doubler votre capacité
de stockage de votre smartphone ce que
j'ai viré mais ici c'est le grand écran
full hd plus le fait d'avoir des hauts
parleurs stéréo même s'il ya un certain
déséquilibre c'est pas extrêmement
graves ont une fois de plus dans
l'entrée de gamme
ne vous attendez pas ici avoir des
performances de dan devait pas venir
faire tourner tous les jeux de dupes les
stars des jeux qui ne sont pas trop
gourmand pour ne pas voir un smartphone
qui rame c'est une certitude
par contre un smartphone qui est très
endurant et qu'il vous lâchera pas avec
sa batterie de une fois de plus 6000
millan perdre ses écrits si noir sur je
ne sais pas dire noir sur blanc dans ces
crimes encore jeune voilà ce que j'avais
à vous dire aujourd'hui sur ce poème 3
dites moi comment vous le trouvez vous
est ce que vous voulez qu'on parle
beaucoup de smartphones dans l'entrée de
gamme ce sont des choses qui vous
intéressent est ce que vous voulez qu'on
passe un peu de temps sur ses
smartphones là où est-ce qu'il préférait
qu'on se concentre dans le milieu de
gamme haut de gamme
mark et moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire et dites moi si vous avez un
smartphone de poko et si celui là
si le m3 peut vous tentez oui non
comment pourquoi
dites moi tout ça on va en commentaire
quant à nous on retrouve très vite pour
continuer à parler de teck
oui ça ne s'arrête jamais est ce qui est
plutôt cool il ya pas te raconter comme
ça beaucoup d'amour des gros bisous et à
très vite pour les soins du butin
[Musique]